>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Catalina Gomez: I
wanted to welcome all
of you today to today's event.
This is our second Hispanic
Heritage Month Program for the year.
We have a wonderful
listing of events
for Hispanic Heritage Month
here at the Library of Congress.
So I wanted to announce that we have
our complete calendar of events here
in the entrance of our room.
It's an honor for me to
introduce our featured speaker,
who happens to be also
my compatriot, my friend,
and an artist that I admire deeply.
Juana Medina is an illustrator
and author of children's books,
as well as a teacher at
George Washington University.
She grew up in Bogata,
Columbia and studied
at the Rhode Island
School of Design.
Medina has -- was the first winner
of the J. Kennedy Memorial
Scholarship, an award given yearly
by the National Cartoonist Society
to top college cartoonists
in North America.
She is also the recipient of a
Marion Vannett Ridgeway Honor Award,
and [inaudible] 100
Columbians, an honor granted
to 100 successful Colombians
living abroad.
Her books for children
include One Big Salad,
A Delicious Counting Book, and
Smick, her latest picture book,
and then Juana and
Lucas, who is actually --
which is actually soon to
be published and we managed
to bring some copies
here for the event,
and it's published Candlewick Press.
Juana and Lucas tells the story
of a young girl's decision
to learn English.
All of her books are on sale
here today at the event,
and I'm also very excited to
announce that Juana Medina is one
of our featured authors
this Saturday
on our National Book Festival
in the convention center.
So I encourage everyone to
go see her there as well.
Her presentation, I
believe, is at two p.m.
at the Children's Literature
Pavilion.
Being an immigrant from Columbia
myself, and an aspiring artist,
I am very, very eager to hear --
to hear about this
wonderful person's journey.
Please join me in welcoming
Juana Melina.
[ Applause ]
>> Juana Medina: Hello.
Thank you very, Catalina, for
such a generous introduction.
I really appreciate it.
First, I want to say hello.
It's absolutely wonderful
to be here.
I really cannot believe it.
Many years ago now when I first got
my reader ID here at the Library
of Congress, I felt elated.
At last I felt like I could take
part in coming to the Library
and taking profit of
all the wonderful things
that take place in this institution.
Later on, a few years later while
working on Smick, I was contacted
by Penguin asking to send my
information so that I could be part
of a catalog, and I thought, great,
my work is now part of the catalog
at the Library of Congress,
a tiny piece of me there.
And so today I'm short of words to
say how exciting it is to be here.
I'm very humbled and
very appreciative,
thank you very much
for this invitation.
Besides saying yes to this,
because of course how could I pass
on this opportunity, then I
realized, okay, what do I do?
What do I talk about?
It wasn't just that simple.
And then after thinking about it
for a while I thought,
okay, I think I got it.
I want to share what it's been
like to be in this journey.
I hope not to put you
sleep by doing this.
I promise I'll keep it brief and
hopefully entertaining enough.
I hope it will be inspiring, whether
you are an artist, or an immigrant,
or Latino or Latina,
or queer, or a woman,
or simply a human being
here present for this talk.
I hope there's something
here for you.
I grew up in Bogota, Colombia,
as Catalina was saying.
And here I am with my
grandfather as a teeny tiny baby.
The Andes in the back
of the picture.
I was very, very lucky to
grow up very close to him.
He was one of the first brain
surgeons to go back to Columbia
after preparing here in the
U.S. There was such a need
for brain surgeons at that
time that apparently when he --
when the airplane landed there
was an ambulance waiting for him
to perform the first surgery.
That was the need for
surgeons at the time.
He was a wonderful human
being, and a wonderful doctor.
He was also somebody who spoiled
me like nobody else in life.
My grandmother was also wonderfully
skilled and a fantastic human being.
She was a wonderful carpenter,
and together they designed some
of the first equipment to
perform surgeries in Columbia
because there was no
equipment in order
for my grandfather
to do the surgery.
So it was a collective effort.
They were both very creative.
Here's my grandma in her studio.
So that was perhaps
genetic, I got lucky.
Their house was actually
magical, not just by my standards,
but my family and my
friends and everybody
around them would just come
oftentimes to their house
and benefit from having a very
inspiring experience thanks
to their creativity
and their generosity.
My parents were basketball players
and they were wonderful athletes.
I did not inherit that
gene [laughter].
My mom at some point,
my atrocious career
in basketball didn't last long,
and at some point we had a very
serious talk about it being okay
for me to quit the basketball team.
So overall, it was a
very happy childhood
and I felt incredibly lucky.
My father died when I was about
seven months old in an accident.
So I must say the strength
and courage
from my mother has been something
that has kept me going
for a very long time.
I'm very lucky to have
her here today.
So that's me with my mom.
One of the hardest things
about growing up in Columbia,
despite me saying I was
very lucky, was the war.
This were the 1980's and
during the '80s the situation
in Columbia was far from peaceful.
It was incredibly,
incredibly hard for very many.
We were, again, lucky to first
be comfortable to live in Bogota,
which was a very extensive city
where people were a lot more
at peace than out in
the countryside.
Still, this doesn't mean we
were not touched by the war.
I still remember, you know,
blasting bombs and, you know,
people being kidnapped around us,
and situations that were quite dire.
But in the grand scheme of
things we were quite lucky
to not be touched directly
by the war.
Bogota is a very diverse city, very
vibrant, very big, and it allowed
for me to have tremendous
inspiration just by hearing stories
from countless people,
who in a very generous
and passionate way do share
stories, very Colombian style just
by simply opening up
and saying hello.
So we were very lucky.
Besides that amazing environment
where storytelling was very
much alive, I happened to grew
up in a household that
was tremendously creative.
These are my cousins.
I'm standing with the red veil.
I have no idea what we were playing.
But, you know, it must've
been quite exciting.
And we were encouraged to think that
way and to create things out of,
you know, whatever we found
around, like a little piece of rag,
and we played for hours and
we were very, very happy.
The only thing I know for certain
in this picture is
Filipe [assumed spelling],
who's in the middle,
was an astronaut.
That's -- that helmet --
that helmet says it all,
and that was his preference.
I also happened to be very
lucky to go to a school
that valued arts tremendously,
and that was very,
very helpful in my upbringing.
It was a wonderful environment
where everybody found
constant ways of expression.
So art and creative expression
were from very early, just simply,
you know, parts of my life.
I didn't question it.
I didn't think of it as art.
I didn't think of it as, you
know, other than just expressing.
And that changed as I
grew a little bit older
and I started meeting people
that didn't grow up in
such a fortunate household
and then they would say
to me, well, I can't draw.
And it's like, what do
you mean you can't draw?
I'll give you my pen,
or you need paper,
or how can we [inaudible] can draw,
but I couldn't really conceive
that people could not draw.
During the 1980's, the late 1980's
also, things changed a little bit
and we were touched by the financial
crisis taking place in Columbia.
And this was quite hard
because we had lived comfortably
and we had had a safe life,
and all of a sudden all
these conditions changed.
So all of a sudden we
had close to nothing,
or we were very uncomfortable
and it was a difficult situation.
And from realizing that there
were very few resources,
or they were quite limited,
thank goodness I grew
up with a very creative
mother and I learned
that having nothing could be
translated into making something.
Everything was an opportunity to
make things and shift things around.
That being creative ensured
that there was some sweetness
in life no matter what, and a little
bit of humor took us a long way.
By the year 2000 my
family ended up leaving
and they came to the United States.
I stayed behind studying
physical therapy.
And talk about being creative,
this was during a financial crisis,
working in very, very
poor hospitals,
and that's where you see most
creativity really at work.
I think we often think of
creatives as entrepreneurs
or designers or craftsmen.
Go to a hospital, go talk
to a physical therapist,
to an occupational therapist, to a
nurse, especially in Latin America
and you will see really
what creativity is at work,
and not necessarily for any
special award or anything,
but simply to improve
somebody's life.
In the end, opportunities were
narrowing for me in Columbia,
and what made most sense
was for me to leave.
This was not an easy goodbye.
I was leaving behind
my grandparents.
And, for some reason, I knew
I wouldn't see them again.
This was incredibly hard.
That goodbye I still can sense
it in me 15 years later almost.
And it wasn't easy, and
I don't think I have
to go extensively about it.
For those of you who might have been
immigrants you all remember this
in some kind of way.
Needless to say, I still remember
and miss those big mountains
and miss the smells of fresh fruit
and fresh flowers everywhere,
and Spanish being spoken loudly
everywhere, but life went on.
I had in my pocket $220.
Like many immigrants, many
had much less than that.
And I also had my bags full of
books and very many expectations.
I was lucky.
I was lucky in many ways.
One of them being I had my family
here, so they were receiving me
as soon as I got off that plane.
I was coming to a city that
I was already familiar with.
I knew the language.
I had been able to receive
wonderful education,
and that made a huge
difference that I'm well aware.
Not every immigrant gets those
possibilities right off an airplane,
or right as they walk
past the frontier.
But that doesn't take away
the amount of uncertainty
when you're an immigrant.
And it's hard, it's
very difficult to figure
out how things will work
out, what is your role,
what are you supposed
to do with your life?
And that prompted questions for me.
Who am I? What does it
mean to be an immigrant?
Because all of a sudden there
so many labels imposed on me.
Where are you from?
When did you came?
What are you doing here?
Are you staying here for good?
It's like, I don't
know, I have no idea.
Back in Columbia my
identity was very clear.
I knew who I was, what I wanted
to do, and here everything shifted
and all I had was a blank slate.
I felt very much like
one in a million.
Nothing seemed to be the experience
that everybody was having.
It seemed to be very
different and foreign to a lot
of people, and that was difficult.
All of a sudden also, I
realized there was a label
that was imposed on me.
I was brown.
I had never been brown
in my life before.
All of a sudden I was -- I would
enter a shop and I would be followed
by the lady at the store, and
I would be stopped by police,
and all these situations that,
again, I'm one of the lucky ones.
But it just seems so foreign to me,
and something I had
never encountered before.
I was the other.
And being the other is very scary.
It's something that shuns us
away, that stops conversations,
that encourages fear,
and we're leaving it --
we're living at quite vividly right
now during this election season.
While I was trying to figure out
what to do with my life I happened
to see that there would be --
that there was a class
going to Georgetown
as a continued education class
that was offered and it was
for drawing and painting critique.
And so I joined this
class just as an effort
to think things differently and I
happened to have the great fortune
of meeting Bill Rock
[assumed spelling],
who was the instructor
of this class.
And we had wonderful conversations,
and he learned a little bit more
about myself as I was
learning about art.
I had never really
taken art seriously.
As I was telling you, I
thought everybody could draw.
And he finally said
to me, well listen,
it seems like things
are not working.
You need to change your visa.
Why do you insist on
physical therapy?
Why don't we make a bet and you
apply to art school and if you get
in you start art --
going to art school.
And I think I was despondent enough
to say, okay, I'll give it a try.
And I applied to the Corcoran and
received a scholarship and I said,
okay, I guess this is
the route I'll take.
This had been after 2 1/2, almost
3 years, of being here in the U.S.
So I started at the Corcoran
and I was incredibly happy
to encounter a whole
lot of opportunities
that I would've never
encountered otherwise.
Also, it guaranteed a student
visa, which was a big relief.
This would ensure that as
long as I was a student here
in the U.S. I would be okay.
But while I was there I realized
that the graphic design program,
which is where I was, wasn't
necessarily what I had in mind.
The program at the time
was very corporate driven.
Things were done using
a lot of computers,
and things were all about, you
know, production of annual reports
and digital works, and I was like,
oh, I want something more tangible,
and I want to get my hands dirty,
and I want to explore more.
And while this was going through
my mind I happened to sign
up for another drawing class,
in this case with the wonderful
artist, Bill Christenberry.
And Bill, in a very gentle
way, almost cornered me one day
and he said, young lady, you
realize this is not a place for you.
And he said, you -- if the world
was perfect where would you go?
And I said to him, well,
if the world was perfect
I would go to RISD.
He said, well just apply, I'll
write a letter of recommendation,
and then all of a sudden things
started working very easily.
And the next semester
I ended up at RISD.
It's not as easy as it
sounds, but just for sake --
for sake of time, yeah, it was
-- it was still quite unexpected.
RISD was like being back at my
grandmother's carpentry studio.
It was just a shop that
extended throughout the city
where everybody was eager
to learn something new,
where everybody was
eager to explore,
where everybody was passionate
and curious about the arts,
and this offered a
wonderful platform for me
to reinvent myself in some way.
Also, at the time, and if
any of you have gone to RISD,
there's a great amount of
self-portrait that you have to do.
They insist on working on
self-portraits and family trees
and exploring who you are,
and that was a lot for me
to figure out at the time.
To add to that, I lost
my grandparents.
And they -- as I said
in the beginning,
they were incredible human beings.
They have -- had been great
support network for me,
and losing them was incredibly hard.
One of the hardest things
about losing them was something
that some Latinos here
might have heard about,
and it's what some call
[speaking foreign language],
or the golden cage, which is
basically being in the U.S.,
being able to take profit
of so many opportunities,
and yet here we are
locked and stuck here.
I could not leave the country
even though I was perfectly legal
because I had asked for a
visa while being in the U.S.
So the moment I left the
United States I would have
to reapply for a visa.
The chances for a mid-20's woman,
single, from Colombia, gay,
who happened to have
her family in the U.S.
to get a visa to come back in, nil.
When the lawyer handed me that visa
he said, if you go to Columbia,
or if you go out of the United
States, I will not represent you.
So it was very clear for me
that I couldn't manage to get
out and come back in again.
This was one of the hardest
things I had to do, and it was one
of the hardest decisions to make,
just keeping a very somewhat cold
mind and letting my grandparents go
without being there for
them in their last days.
And all these questions between
self-portraits and family trees
and all the things
that were going on,
people started asking
me who are you?
Because I was clearly not the
traditional New England student
at the Rhode Island
School of Design.
And that made me ask,
yeah, who am I?
Who am I? And I started
thinking of self as an artist.
And I started thinking of self.
And the more I thought the more I
realized the only way to solve this
or to find enlightenment in
some kind of way would be
through exploration, because I
clearly didn't have the answers.
So there was a lot of observation
and exploration through the means
that were familiar to
me, and that was drawing.
So I drew the things I missed about
Columbia, like fruits organized
in the grocery store, or cars
beeping horns, or fountains,
or coffee shops, and
[inaudible], bus brakes screeching,
and the big windows, and the
sun hitting the mountains almost
as if they could be split open.
And this -- memories started
filling my journals and sketchbooks.
Then I moved on try to see the world
from a different interpretation,
and that would be through
Latin American literature.
And perhaps in a crazy attempt
I decided to sign up for a class
that was called Magical
Realism and South.
So it was the first time
in my life I would attempt
to read Garcia Marquez in
English surrounded by people
who knew very little about him,
and to learn not just to reminisce
and to capture the essence of
my culture from my perspective,
but also how others
were perceiving it.
I remember an architecture
student during class saying,
well this book is ridiculous.
I mean, they talk about
people licking the walls.
Where would that happen?
And I would think, yeah,
that happens in my country.
People do lick the walls
because they have salt deficiency
and there's cal on the wall
so they lick the walls.
But it's the understanding of
a completely different world
and trying to find a way to
bridge those differences.
So I started looking around me and
collecting objects through visuals.
Everything was an opportunity
to draw.
So my socks, a hat,
a pen, a paper --
a piece of paper, a
car that passed by,
absolutely everything would
be recorded in drawing form.
I sometimes wonder,
if somebody saw these
without any explanation they would
think I'm the most OCD person
in the world.
It's absolutely nuts to see this.
But at the same time, that was my
possibility of exploring things
and observing objects
that were familiar
and were foreign at the time.
It was basically changing my entire
perspective on how to see the world,
or at least an attempt on doing so.
I tried to record the architecture
around me very different
from the houses that I
grew up seeing in Colombia.
These are roofs on
Benefit [phonetic] Street
in Providence, Rhode Island.
I started recording the
buildings that I walked past
and then reinterpreting
them in my own way.
I would also record my dreams.
This was a dream of a
crazy, big turnip that --
I was in a farmer's community and in
my dream they needed help to take it
out of the earth because
it was so, so big,
and I still remember
vividly the colors.
I don't think I was able to --
I can tell I wasn't able to portray
exactly what I saw in my dream,
which was absolutely surreal,
but still, this was my attempt.
So it all took practice.
It took a lot of practice just
drawing, playing with humor.
This is a sneeze.
Doing more serious things
in the classroom and studio.
Recording buildings, rerecording
them using different media
and trying to explore
what this meant for me.
What is the influence
of this over me?
Or how can I possibly influence
it by drawing it somehow.
Of course failure was also a great
part of this, and it's something
that in the arts and being
creative there's no way to escape.
But one thing was very clear, and
it was that drama should stay away
from all these explorations.
It was simply failing
and starting again
but not letting myself
just lose my mind simply
because I couldn't register
things how I intended to.
And this also was filtering
into my life obviously.
It was not just about a very
serious exploration on drawing,
but instead just trying to
externalize all the questions
and all the anguish
that was going inside.
And then the other essential
part for me became iterations.
This is a big bad wolf on a
retake on Little Red Riding Hood,
and I decided to tell the story from
-- with a little bit of a spinoff.
I don't know if you can
see clearly from there,
but Red Riding Hood is walking,
she's all of a sudden attacked
by the wolf, but not to eat her
or eat her treats or anything,
but all he wanted was the cape.
And so he's dancing and prancing
and then at the end he flies.
So that's one interpretation.
Then I drew another interpretation
where the -- instead of --
instead of the, you know,
story that we had before,
or with the super flying
wolf, I just decided
to have little red riding hood
say, okay, enough of this.
I need my cape back
and then on they went.
The other great factor
besides observation,
iteration, failing, was process.
And I just have one single
example of process here,
and it's just documenting the
buildup of an illustration
that was later used for a
documentary through PBS.
It was about a -- the story
of two Colombian women,
two very brave Colombian women.
One of them, the mother, who
was kidnapped for seven years.
The other, the daughter,
who happened to be
in D.C. while her mother
was kidnapped in the jungle
of Columbia for a number of years.
So I wanted to have both
worlds come together somehow.
So you can see to the -- to
the left Washington, D.C.,
and you might find some of those
buildings a little bit familiar.
And then towards the
right the jungle.
So here's a close-up of Washington,
D.C. And in the animation I made
the, you know, the little red lights
at the top of the George Washington
Monument flicker and the lights
in the -- in the Kennedy Center
move around a little bit, and so on.
So detail was, of course,
imperative.
The other thing I decided to
take on was to take great leaps,
and these were unexpected leaps,
but in a way it was just learning
to say yes to projects
that came my way.
And I applied all of these things,
as I was saying, observation,
exploration, iteration,
failure, process,
and not only to work
or life, but to play.
And this allowed for me to have a
much easier platform to navigate.
And whenever I was asked
by then, who are you?
At least I could, you know, come
up with an answer just based
on what I had been working on.
Not everything was done on my own.
I was also very lucky to
find wonderful mentors
who offered extraordinary
examples to follow.
And they also made sure to point
out examples not to follow,
and for that I'm tremendously
grateful.
As I noticed through their
work, and the work I was doing,
and how I was encountering
the world,
I recognized that one very
important thing was to be kind,
that kindness goes a
really, really long way.
The other thing I realized is
that working hard does help a lot.
And being an immigrant, it's
not just hard, it's hard.
And because of that hard work
and to keep a balance in life
and to not go bitter about all
the work that was being done,
it was important to have fun.
And so I decided to keep these three
rules for whatever I was doing,
and I still try to keep them.
Now following rules is not
easy, but I certainly try.
Being an immigrant makes
things even harder.
The level of uncertainty
makes it very difficult,
so as graduation got
closer and closer,
there I was hunting
again for a visa.
So what next?
What could I do after all the effort
that I had been putting into my work
and considering myself
a creative person?
I noticed that many of my
characteristics were considered
by society as disadvantages, and
I realized that I couldn't put it
in their shoulders to turn those
disadvantages into advantages,
that it was completely up to me.
And I thought if it is up
to me I won't turn them only
into advantages, but big
advantages and make sure
that I would become indispensable.
I don't know how to do
absolutely extraordinary things
that will save humanity, that is
not the way I become indispensable,
but in the work I do and how I
do it, that's how I could keep
on working hard, being kind, and
having fun, and making things
as seemingly indispensable
as possible.
In one of those efforts I
became a VIP guide for RISD.
And what this meant was I was
touring all the VIP visitors
that came to RISD,
showing them the buildings
and what was going
on around the school.
And this allowed for absolutely
fantastic conversations,
and most of them would say to
me, what do you want to do?
What is it that you want to do?
And I would say, I just
want to tell stories.
And these incredible men and women
would be very kind until I would say
that and then they would
say, you can't do that,
you have to do something
more than just tell stories.
It's not -- I mean, are
you going to tell stories?
Are you going to write books?
Are you going to make movies?
What are you going to do?
And I would say, stories,
that's what I really want to do.
No, not a possibility.
So I just said, okay,
I'll do it on my own.
I kept on working hard
and harder and harder.
And I got, again, very
lucky and while I was trying
to figure [inaudible] visa would
come after being a student,
I happened to meet Eileen Morrison.
Eileen Morrison is not only a
fantastic immigration lawyer,
but an extraordinary human being.
And where many had said
to me, there's no option,
perhaps if you find somebody to
get married, or do something that,
you know, is perhaps not
the most Orthodox option,
they would say, there's
no possibility.
Eileen instead looked at
all my work and she said,
let's try, let's give this a try.
And she didn't give up and she
very sharply took everything I had.
She didn't make any
promises she couldn't,
but she put in her best work,
and this was the most inspiring
thing I have seen when I was
in a very, very dire situation.
So I said before, you know, how
I had decided to take these rules
of being kind, of working
hard, and having fun,
but this took it to
a whole new level.
Yeah, over three years of waiting,
of jumping at any project I could,
of still trying to keep my life
together, and it wasn't easy.
It wasn't easy at all.
The uncertainty was despair inducing
because it affects every
single inch of your life.
Do I buy this book I love?
But if I have to leave the country
in 30 days why would I buy it?
Do I really want to make this
incredible friendship or what seems
like -- well, I might be gone.
Any conversation, it just seeps in
and it's incredibly
hard to shake it off.
Decision-making is hard,
as I said, you know.
Do I take a new phone plan even
though my flip phone is broken
and it's partly working?
Well, you don't want to get
into a contract if you are going
to need to leave in no time.
Uncertainty could easily
drive anybody insane.
And, finally, before
losing it, I decided, okay,
what is under my control?
What can I change to make
things easier for myself?
So I decided to reach out and
to share my personal story,
something I wasn't
adamant to do earlier.
It was just, no, work will do it,
work will do it, and that's it.
And I started realizing that
sharing my story allowed for empathy
to start building, and then
people would have references,
or people to point me to, and
things would start changing.
And I allowed for others
to elevate me
and to think of things differently.
So taking on those personal
challenges and continuing
to create was imperative
throughout that time.
I also tried my best to aim
high and turn every disadvantage
into an advantage, to make sure
that the uncertainty would
be countered by adaptability.
I don't know if there
are many Colombians here,
but -- or [inaudible].
In Columbia, in Bogata there's
a market called San Andresito.
And San Andresito, whenever you go
there you can you can find anything
you're looking for.
And if you don't find what you're
looking for, they'll tell you all,
oh, I don't have this, but
I have this, and I don't --
and, you know, they'll
figure it out until you end
up buying whatever it is.
And I thought -- I never
thought I would find wisdom
in San Andresito, but there I was.
They would call, Juana, will
you do this annual report?
Yes. Will you do this animation?
Yes. Will you do whatever it was?
Yes, I'll do it, it doesn't matter.
Of course, I was collapsing out
of all the work I was taking on,
but it just meant a
possibility and an opportunity.
Meanwhile, Eileen kept
on working on making sure
that I could get a
visa as an artist.
And then I got a denial,
and it was as hard
as a breakup, or even harder.
It -- just the idea of, you know,
yeah, you're good but not that good.
It was basically what that eight
page letter was telling me.
So I was losing it.
Moreover, this process was very
expensive and I didn't have a lot
of money just to keep
on going and spending.
But I knew I needed to stay here
and that there was no reason
after all those years of hard work
to go back to Columbia and give up.
Throughout the time, of course,
there were ongoing
conversations with my mother.
And one day in particular
she pointed out to me, Juana,
this is very much like
swimming 1500 meters.
One thing I didn't tell
you early on in an attempt
to make the story shorter,
was that I was a swimmer
for a very long time, a
competitive swimmer, and believe it
or not I would swim
1500 meters as --
that was what I would
compete on most at my meets.
And 1500 meters is
a long, long swim.
And your head feels like
it's bursting, your eyes
and the goggles feel like they're
going to bulge out of your head.
You barely have the
physical stamina,
even though I was training
four hours a day,
going an hour to the gym,
it's very, very hard to do.
And the moment my mom said this
it was clear to me that I had
within me the tools to keep
on swimming and to keep
on going forward, and to
treat things basically
as if it was a 1500 meter meet.
There I am.
I'm [inaudible] but,
you know, just try.
So onward, and I kept
being persistent.
And I had to be very,
very pragmatic,
which as a Colombian wasn't
part -- wasn't easy to do.
So I had to think of
myself as a phone battery
and having 15% of battery left.
If you have a 15% battery
left you don't check Facebook.
You don't waste time, you know,
chatting with somebody really don't
feel like chatting, or doing things
that are unnecessary, because
you have to save that battery.
And I felt that I had that --
a lot of energy and I could not
lose it being tremendously dramatic
or petty or crying about
things, and instead I had
to keep a mentality of, okay,
that denial was very hard.
Now what next?
How can we overcome this?
So, fortunately enough, we had
done a second filing of a visa
and just kept on going
hoping for that to go well.
And then when pragmatism doesn't
work, there's optimism, and of that,
fortunately as Colombian,
I did have my fair share.
Thank goodness by the -- by
mid-December in 2012 I received one
of the most delightful
calls I've received.
Eileen, my lawyer, called to say
that my visa had been approved.
We both cried on the phone.
We both celebrated.
I still can't get over it.
And that night of the 12th I
slept like I hadn't in years.
For those of you who have waited for
a visa, you know what that means.
Shortly after I got a book
deal that made me feel
like the effort was
entirely worth it.
I have been showing some of
the illustrations of the book
within this presentation.
That book is called Juana and
Lucas and it's back there.
And this validated a lot of
the work that I had been doing.
Moreover, I happened to
meet Sally, my partner,
and this was within a span of three
months, and I thought, oh my gosh,
is this whole year
going to go this way?
So it was in a way a new
life and a way to see
that hard work had paid off,
that there was definitely
a certain amount of luck,
but a lot of it had been that
persistence, that pragmatism,
that optimism just in the right
dose to make things happen.
So is now everything perfect?
No, but darn close, and for
that I think it's worth saying
that the journey was humbling,
very reassuring, fortunately,
and tremendously inspiring.
And for that I'm grateful.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> Catalina Gomez: Thank
you so much, Juana,
for this beautiful,
beautiful presentation.
Again, we're selling
the books in the back.
And also I wanted to announce
that we have this little
survey close to the exit here.
They're from our office
of communications.
If you have a second to fill those
out we would really appreciate it.
Thank you again for coming.
>> Can I ask you a question?
>> Juana Medina: Sure, yeah.
>> Catalina Gomez: Questions,
yeah, we have questions.
We're speechless, I'm speechless.
>> Juana Medina: Yes [inaudible]?
>> When you're doing the
illustrations with the food,
do you have any set way of
designing the illustrating first,
or do you see a piece of food and --
>> Juana Medina: It's mostly the
food first, and that does help.
With the latest series of books
that I've been working with food,
there has been some theme set up
beforehand so that I have an idea
of what I have to -- you know, the
parameters I have to work within.
But if it's just for fun I'll
look at a carrot and see,
you know, what ends up happening.
So it's not necessarily
prescribed, yeah.
>> Like the radish that
you showed a minute ago.
>> Juana Medina: Yeah.
>> Do you draw from a photograph
or [inaudible] like that?
[inaudible] on paper and
then you put the food there,
but that's not possible.
>> Juana Medina: Right.
Yeah, so initially I did
start drawing with pen and ink
around the fruit that I was
using, and then I realized
that it's a lot easier to
just photograph the food
because it has such
a short lifespan.
So just to photograph the food, take
it into Photoshop and try all sorts
of iterations, so that guaranteed
that I could play a
lot more with it.
So, yeah, this is Photoshop.
And then I can use it, you know,
for however many times I want, yeah.
Yes?
[ Inaudible ]
>> Absolutely, yes.
There have been many influences.
I think being a child,
Quentin Blake,
Jules Feiffer, Kino [phonetic].
I'm blanking right now but,
you know, there were so --
yeah, Cheryl Steinberg
[assumed spelling],
were of great inspiration.
And then I started learning a
whole new amount of illustrators
and cartoonists and that definitely
was humbling and so inspiring.
Moreover, and thanks for your
question, as Catalina was saying,
winning the National Cartoonist
Society J. Kennedy Memorial
Scholarship was a wonderful way of
connecting with many cartoonists,
and that guaranteed that
I could learn from them,
not just about their work, but
their personal experience with art,
and that was a -- you know, just
a great privilege really, yeah.
[ Inaudible ]
That's a really good question.
So with Juana and Lucas, the story
was very clear from the beginning.
I'll just tell you very briefly.
What happened was my mom picked
me up at school and I was fuming
and furious, and she
asked what was going on.
And I said, well they want me to
learn something called the English.
I really don't want to learn this.
And she said, well, we're
going to Disney World
and Mickey Mouse only speaks English
so you might want to give it a try.
And that kind of solved it.
So the structure of
the story was there
and it was very clear
what I wanted to do.
And when I started presenting
the pitch for the story
to different publishing houses
I got all sorts of answers.
Within those answers
there were some that said,
you know, Bogata is too remote.
Nobody really knows about Columbia.
Why we should kids in the
U.S. learn about Columbia?
That's not interesting.
Some were saying, well,
this is very exciting.
The character is very cute.
Why don't we make them Mexican,
and instead of a dog we give
her a burro, and instead of --
you know, oh she would be
so cute with a sombrero.
And I was like, Jesus,
do they realize how offensive
this is just, you know?
And moreover, unfortunately,
I've never been to Mexico
so how could I tell the story.
And so it was really interesting.
Or turning her -- the
character into an immigrant
and being at Jackson Heights.
And I thought that's perfectly
valid, but it's not my experience.
I can't really speak of that.
So that was a point where instead
of yes, I had to very kindly decline
and say no, and know
exactly what I wanted to do.
And that's hard, especially
after saying yes so many times
to everything, and not
knowing if that no is going
to cut my opportunities
that are lying ahead.
Yeah. Yes?
>> Speaking of Columbia, how does
[inaudible] is that tomorrow?
>> Juana Medina: It's --
the voting is next week.
I'm so moved.
I am so moved to think that after
so, so many years we are going
to see peace in our lifetime.
That is the most exciting
thing I can think of.
And I truly hope that all of us
Colombians will be able to see
that in some kind of way.
Is this peace treaty perfect?
No, but no peace is
going to be perfect.
It's -- there's been so much pain
and so many violations of everything
that it's impossible
to think of a way
that would erase the
problematic entirely, but I truly,
truly hope for a yes and that
people will see the value
of what has been done in
Cuba in all the talks.
Yeah. Yeah.
Yes?
>> How much of a culture
shock was [inaudible]?
>> Juana Medina: Oh,
it was interesting
because my grandparents lived in
Boston for a while, so I had grown
up hearing a lot of stories about
Boston and I -- we had visited.
So it wasn't a tremendous shock,
until conversations
started to come forward.
I remember in particular talking
to somebody for about half an hour
and she must have been
completely absent-minded and all
of a sudden she turns to
me and she says, you know,
I just realized this is the first
person, I talked to a brown person.
And I couldn't even
think of what to say.
So, yeah, there have
been interesting things,
but not all of them have
happened in New England.
I love New England.
I'll be there in a week
or so, and I love it.
But it was interesting.
D.C. also has -- I mean, I
remember I was volunteering
at Walter Reed Army Medical Center,
and on my first day this very
kind woman was guiding me
through the hospital, which is huge.
This was at the prior location.
And all of a sudden
she said, wait hold on,
I need to show you something,
because I had told
her I was Colombian
and I had just arrived
and all these things.
And she said, let me show
you, this is an elevator.
If you press this button you go up.
If you press this button
you go down.
And I was like, wow, you know, we
don't have those in the jungle.
I mean, it's just like, oh my God.
I mean, how do you
even -- so I just said,
thank you, thank you very much.
And then later on --
because I think people most
of the time do it out of kindness.
And there's some nervousness
and simply not knowing.
And I'm sure I have said
awful, awful things to people,
you know, in many situations.
So it was hard.
At the end of the, you know, just a
few minutes later we were standing
in line and she said, so
how is the cultural shock?
You know, how hard has it
been to adapt to the city?
And I said, you know, I feel
like I'm in a small town.
It feels so tiny and the
buildings are so short.
And she was like, really?
Really? So, yeah, I think, again,
kindness goes a long way, yeah.
>> I hear that you're
going to participate
in a project with [inaudible].
Can you comment a little about this?
>> Juana Medina: You
heard right, yes.
I can barely contain
myself about this project.
I'm so excited.
Can I say the name?
Catalina [inaudible] will be
joining many young readers
through her Technicolor Adventures.
And the poet laureate has been
writing absolutely fantastic,
just such beautiful
versus for this project.
And we'll be collaborating.
He will be writing.
I will be illustrating.
And there's a whole team
behind us guaranteeing
that everything will turn
out as well as it can go.
And it'll be a great
collaboration with second graders.
>> Second and third graders.
>> Second and third graders,
so we can't wait [inaudible]
come up with, yeah.
Yeah? That was your question?
Oh great. Good.
All right.
Well, thank you very much.
Thank you [applause].
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gove.